Silver State Schools Credit Union the
sponsors of this segment prioritize
people over profit I sat down with CEO
and president Scott a Arcos to find out
how they apply this to their members and
to the community welcome back to the
show Scott so good to have you thank you
Mercedes I appreciate it always good to
be here well you know with increased
prices and Rising interest rates a lot
of people are delaying a new car
purchase this year how can Silver State
Schools Credit Union help with that well
you're absolutely right under these
conditions that may be better to
actually retain your current vehicle and
refinance it and so Silver State School
Credit Union has a thing called a better
car loan also known as the ABC Auto Loan
and that gives you the opportunity to
save up to two percent off your current
auto loan rate when you refinance your
current auto loan with us and through
the end of the year you can also benefit
from 90 days to the first payment now
who wouldn't want 90 days to the first
payment at the Holiday times and so in
other words this program allows you to
lower your interest rate reduce your
monthly auto loan payment and also
utilize those savings on that 90-day
deferral for a holiday expenses so all
loans of course are subject to approval
but to learn more about that program
visit
silverstatecu.com
ABC loan and and you can get more
details that way that sounds like such
such a great option one thing I really
love just being a member of Silver State
Schools Credit Union is the people that
I get to see every time I go in there
and you're hiring so how can someone
become a team member of ssscu and maybe
one day help me with my deposits and
withdrawals I'm glad you asked Mercedes
and yes we are hiring um so Silver State
Schools Credit Union is looking for
individuals who are passionate about
making a difference and our members
day-to-day lives and so our team members
benefit from medical dental vision
insurance a believe it or not a six
percent match 401k plan and paid time
off actually a very liberal paid time
off and so we're actually hosting a
hiring event with interviews and on the
spot job offers for anyone interested in
becoming a branch or call center team
member and we've got interview
appointments that are available for our
Saturday November 19th event and for
details interview times and and to apply
visit
silverstatecu.com uh and and you can get
more information on our hiring event
that sounds so great and another great
thing about the credit Union is that you
are collecting non-perishable food items
to benefit local students I love this
how can the community participate yep we
certainly are a Mercedes and that Silver
State Schools Credit Union as you know
uh giving back to the community is
extremely important to us so we have an
annual food drive and that's now
underway through November 19th and that
supports students and their families at
our local Focus schools which are Rex
Bell Elementary and Stanford Elementary
as well as the girls empowerment Middle
School also known as gems anyone can
help by donating canned or
non-perishable food items at any one of
our 10 branches throughout the Las Vegas
and Valley and Henderson
thank you to Silver State Schools Credit
Union for sponsoring this segment call
702-733-8820 or visit silverstatecu.com
for more details Las Vegas now will
return unless